let's talk about this how do you find
time to go to South Africa with your
very busy schedule and shoot a show of
this magnitude
um well
covid helped a little bit as far as
having a break
having time to really do whatever the
five of us needed or wanted to do yeah
um
when the creator of the show approached
me uh
the first time I heard the idea of the
show I wasn't 100 on board I heard the
name and I was like ah
this sounds like another like America's
Next Top Model or one of those things
which sure great yeah but
then I said to my friend that brought it
to me I said can I please speak to the
producers or the creator of the show I'd
like to know more
and when I spoke to Caroline uh
by the end of that Zoom I was like where
do I sign let's go let's do this this is
incredible
cannot wait to be a part of something so
inspiring
where are we shooting Africa okay never
been Let's Go 23 hours later we get
there and uh it was the most beautiful
experience
both with the show being in Sun City
yeah
the locals the people the culture the
Safari all of it it was it was just it
was just rad that's amazing it was rad
when you talk about the definition of
beauty I mean it means so many different
things to different people and to you
what is beautiful these days
to me beautiful is
self-reflection
um
to me beautiful is being perfectly
imperfect
nobody's perfect and everybody is
beautiful
doesn't matter your weight your gender
your race your age
um
if you can love yourself from the inside
out
you're you're then you're already
winning yeah unfortunately in today's
world it's a social media driven world
it's an external validation World
instant gratification yes and it's
everybody thinks based on the stigma and
The Stereotype of what we're thrown at
in our face daily instantly yeah that's
what you're supposed to look like that's
how you're supposed to dress that's how
you're supposed to act
and that's such a farce yeah everybody's
unique
um and sure
if you're inspired by someone's fashion
or by their look you can pull from that
and try and experiment fine
but it doesn't necessarily mean that's
what you have to do to be cool or hip or
trending yeah now you're also a dad
you've got two incredible girls I do and
we've got social media we've got
magazines we've got all of that how do
you help them
find their own definition of beauty and
help them be comfortable with that
because for starters there's no social
media for them not allowed
um
even YouTube I have to YouTube kids I
got to put all the filters on yeah
because you don't know what the hell is
going to pop up anymore
um my oldest has an Instagram that my
wife and I run and it's all based on
Dance both my girls are in competitive
dance
uh they're both entertainers just like
their daddy love it
um but
the way that my wife and I try to parent
our kids is again
everyone is beautiful everyone is unique
my youngest has come to me a few times
upset daddy why don't I not look like my
you know Sister
um and I said that's because you're you
yeah you're unique your sister's unique
you're both beautiful in your own ways
and you're both perfect in your own ways
you don't have to look like somebody
else to be perfect
uh or to be beautiful
um and I've explained that Daddy got
bullied when I was a kid yeah because I
try to be different and then
I got suckered into
well if if being different is going to
get me bullied then I'm just going to be
exactly what everybody else is I'm going
to be cookie cutter I'm going to dress
like you I'm gonna act like you because
that's what's cool and then over the
years I realized that's not cool another
great example of
what we need more of is someone like
lizzo she is proud she is loud and she
is not ashamed she is vulnerable she is
honest she's raw yeah
and that's what I love about people like
her we need more people like that that
are just saying hey
this is beautiful this is me I am
beautiful no matter what if I have extra
extra skin here if I have whatever
whatever it doesn't matter because I
know myself inside yeah and
what these amazing contestants had to go
through to find themselves
and to believe in themselves was such an
amazingly beautiful Journey yeah when
I'm on stage I'm impenetrable that's my
little bubble that's my safe place
um when I'm home with my family that's
my safe place when I'm on my own
sometimes
I get in my head I get in my own way
yeah and a lot of these people that were
on the show a lot of these amazing
people have gotten in their own way or
people have gotten in their way and have
told them you're not good enough
you will never amount to anything
and when you get to a place in your life
when you truly believe you're no better
and no worse than the person sitting
next to you
will you truly find happiness and I have
a tattoo I just recently got that is a I
believe it's an old Chinese proverb
true Victory is victory over oneself yes
and that is what I would hope people
take from this show is
when you can overcome your own demons
your own fears your own doubts nobody
can tear you down ever again so then I
ask you this are you there yet no
I'm not there yet
it's and I may never completely get
their Journey but I'm now living life on
life's terms where before I tried to
manipulate my life I tried to I tried to
purposely navigate where
I'd rather just let life come at me and
let me accept the life that is given to
me
as opposed to trying to manipulate
manipulate it and all this stuff and and
listen to other people's opinions and
run with that you don't know me
I'm still learning me sure so if if I
don't know me you darn sure don't know
me yeah and
hearing a lot of the stories that I
heard from all these amazing people
I related to every single one of them
every single one of them on a different
level
and we had some amazing conversations
and soul filler uppers I bet yeah yeah
one last question that we love is
Backstreet Boys coming up with their
30th Anniversary how are you going to
celebrate will you come back to Toronto
and do a special date that I we can all
come to and hang out today be a private
event at your house oh amazing I can't
you know
the way that we're looking at it is this
is our 30th anniversary year yes
um
April 20th is our actual anniversary day
we're all pretty burnt out we have one
final leg left of the DNA World Tour so
everyone's taking a well-needed break
but what I'm doing that day okay uh I
will be live streaming uh I'm getting my
first ever Backstreet Boys tattoo
uh I've never had one in 30 years where
where can I ask I don't even know where
I'm gonna put it yet but probably on my
ribs or somewhere okay somewhere on the
body I don't have a lot of room left on
the arms okay but I just want to get
Backstreet Boys yeah established 1993
Dash Infinity
because even when the group does decide
to be done the music's going to live on
for the rest of our lives so Backstreet
Boys will never be done amazing thank
you so much